[Music]
the last time the world witnessed a
total solar eclipse was in 2017 and its
presence delighted enthusiastic sky
watchers this is absolutely insane but
what if instead of a rare phenomena a
total solar eclipse became an everyday
thing would you live in complete
darkness when does a total solar eclipse
occur and what would happen to the moon
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there were a permanent solar
eclipse a dragon devouring the Sun a
giant Puma demon a pair of sky wolves
throughout history and across cultures
an eclipse has been interpreted as a
perplexing or fearful event even the
2017 total eclipse raised claims of
impending apocalypse by evangelists
groups in the United States
but what if the next Eclipse didn't end
in this scenario we're talking about a
total solar eclipse which only happens
under very specific circumstances first
it has to be a new moon phase second the
moon has to be at its closest position
to earth also called perigee and third
the moon has to be directly in front of
the Sun it's like a sunset this rare
planetary alignment would suddenly
become a normal occurrence but don't
worry you wouldn't live in the moon's
shadow all the time there are two parts
to the moon's shadow the Umbra is the
dark center and the pen Umbra is the
outside edge where only part of the Sun
is blocked by the moon the Umbra has a
diameter of 267 kilometers which is
about the size of the state of West
Virginia in the United States because of
the Earth's axis this large shadow would
sweep across different parts of the
globe during different seasons the rest
of the planet would be in the penumbra
you still get sunlight just not as much
as you used to and life would certainly
be a little dimmer
existence on earth is closely tied to
the transition of day tonight a total
solar eclipse would disrupt this pattern
and wreak havoc on other natural cycles
under the Umbra the temperature would
drop about five degrees even minimal
fluctuations have significant impact
temperature changes and lack of sunshine
are not great for agriculture so we
would have to get creative with growing
our crops in this new cycle of light and
dark we would also see an increase in
seasonal affective disorder or sad this
subtype of depression occurs during long
winter months in high latitudes with
lack of sunshine you'd probably feel
some of the same hopelessness and loss
of energy under the moon's shadow though
we'd have to come up with a new
diagnosis maybe Eclipse affective
disorder in a typical total solar
eclipse the Umbra moves across the globe
from west to east lasting only about
seven and a half minutes this is because
the moon rotates around the earth making
a static Eclipse impossible so the only
way we could see a permanent solar
eclipse is if the moon stopped rotating
around the earth
without its own trajectory the moon
wouldn't be able to resist the
gravitational pull from earth and would
eventually destroy us
then a total eclipse really would be a
doomsday warning observing a total solar
eclipse is a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity let's hope it stays the
Marvel it is life on Earth relies on the
predictable pattern of the Sun and the
moon and we would be in big trouble if
our orderly cosmos changed if planet
Earth screeched to a halt and stopped
orbiting around the Sun what then
well that's a story for another what-if
[Music]